unless you've been living on mars you've
probably
noticed a conflict between islam and the
west
on the issue of freedom of speech why is
there a conflict
well it's now firmly embedded in many
western legal systems and constitutions
that we have the right to criticize and
mock any position we want
islam claims that you don't have a right
to criticize or mock muhammad
because criticizing and mocking muhammad
is forbidden
in islam so we have a disagreement here
jihadis have been slaughtering people
for making fun of muhammad
for 14 centuries and the violence is
going to continue until
something changes either western nations
back down
and outlaw criticism of muhammad or
jihadis stop
killing over criticism of muhammad
jihadis want a world where they can
criticize and mock your religion but
you can't criticize or mock their
religion youtube
has been favoring the jihadi side for
several years now but the trust and
safety team
is making it more obvious than ever
let's look at two examples from the past
week
hi act 17 apologetics our team has
reviewed your content
and unfortunately we think it violates
our hate speech policy we've removed the
following content
from youtube video islam's free speech
hypocrisy
that video is on bit shoot the link is
in the description box
in the video i quote some muslim leaders
demanding a ban
on speech that offends muslims i then go
on
to point out that there's a lot of
speech in islam's most trusted sources
that's offensive to non-muslims i then
tell muslims that if they want to ban
offensive speech they'll need to ban
their own book but that if they don't
want to ban their own book
they shouldn't be calling for a ban on
offensive speech
according to youtube exposing hypocrisy
is hate speech we know that this might
be disappointing
but it's important to us that youtube is
a safe place for all
if content breaks our rules we remove it
if you think we've made a mistake you
can appeal and we'll take another look
keep reading for more details how your
content violated the policy
content glorifying or inciting violence
against another person or group of
people
is not allowed on youtube anyone ever
seen
or heard me glorify or incite violence
against
anyone we also don't allow any content
that encourages hatred of another person
or group of people based on their
membership
in a protected group anyone ever heard
me encourage
hatred of another person or group of
people
based on their membership in a protected
group
some muslims will say yes you criticize
our prophet
that's encouraging hatred against us and
therein lies the problem
criticizing positions is not encouraging
hatred but many muslims view it that way
and obviously so does youtube
but if a muslim criticizes or mocks
christianity
somehow that won't be encouraging hatred
youtube is just as hypocritical as islam
notice the other problem here what is
this
protected group youtube refers to
the protected group is muslims
according to youtube muslims who make up
nearly a quarter of the world's
population
are a protected group are christians a
protected group
absolutely not are atheists a protected
group
absolutely not notice youtube's policy
if you're a christian or an atheist and
a muslim criticizes your views
he's totally fine because you're not a
member of a protected group
but if you criticize the muslims views
you're guilty of hate speech because the
muslim is a member of a protected group
according to youtube then muslims can
criticize your views
but you can't criticize their views
remind me what was the goal of jihadis
beheading teachers and slaughtering
random people over cartoons
terrorists are trying to create a world
where they can criticize
your views but you can't criticize
theirs
whose side is youtube on the side
of the terrorists youtube goes on to say
that they've given me a strike for hate
speech
and that they've banned me from posting
for a week which is why
i'm on the apostate prophet's channel i
immediately appealed the strike i wrote
to the trust and safety team
the only hate speech in this video is
speech i'm criticizing
i'm responding to people who are calling
on western governments
to outlaw cartoons of muhammad and to
people who think that violence is
appropriate
if western governments do not outlaw
cartoons of muhammad
i point out that if they really believe
that offensive speech or mockery
should be banned then their own
religious texts
should be banned because these texts are
offensive to many people
my message is that we shouldn't ban
speech simply because
it offends someone and that it's
hypocritical to say
ban speech that offends me but it's okay
if my speech offends you
the fact that youtube is banning my
speech because i'm defending consistency
and freedom of speech is simply
amazing pretty straightforward
i checked back about an hour after
submitting the appeal
and the appeal had already been rejected
so
if a muslim demands laws against
offensive speech
and you point out that there's offensive
speech in the quran
you are guilty of hate speech according
to the geniuses on the youtube trust and
safety team
but the trust and safety team never
sleeps so
early this morning i received this hi
axe 17 apologetics our team has reviewed
your content
and unfortunately we think it violates
our hate speech policy
we've removed the following content from
youtube
video the religion of peace polka
featuring keyboard jihadist
in that video all i did was post some
comments of keyboard jihadis who were
threatening to kill me
along with my responses which were
totally peaceful
here again the video is on my bit shoot
channel the link is in the description
box
we know that this might be disappointing
but it's important to us that youtube
is a safe place for all then shouldn't
you be banning the people who are
threatening to kill me
and not me the one who's being targeted
by the jihadis
and by the trust and safety team two
groups that
always seem to be on the same side if
content breaks our rules
we remove it if you think we've made a
mistake
you can appeal and we'll take another
look keep reading for more details
how your content violated the policy
content glorifying or inciting violence
against another person
or group of people is not allowed on
youtube
we also don't allow any content that
encourages hatred
of another person or group of people
based on their membership
in a protected group so now
if a muslim threatens to kill you on
youtube
and you point out that the muslim just
threatened you
you're guilty of glorifying or inciting
violence and encouraging
hate against a member of a protected
group
according to the youtube trust and
safety team
if a muslim threatens to kill you you
have to keep your mouth shut about it
because if you draw attention to the
death threat
you're encouraging hatred against the
muslim
this is why i deleted my facebook
account a keyboard jihadi
would threaten to kill me i would take a
screenshot and say
hey look at this guy threatening to kill
me and facebook would ban me
for hate speech i got sick of it
the people running the trust and safety
teams of all of the major social media
platforms are stupid
evil and insane these stupid evil insane
people control
what billions of people can and cannot
say
i think that's a bigger problem than
jihad
one of the most important things we can
do now is expose the bias
and hypocrisy and insanity of the
platforms
i'd actually love to see youtube explain
the policies it's been enforcing
unfortunately youtube makes it almost
impossible to contact anyone
who can give you a real answer about
anything
the only exception i see is the at team
youtube page on twitter
they do answer lots of questions that
people send them
again my banned videos have been
uploaded to bitshoot
the links are in the description box
if you'd like youtube to explain their
policies
just send one of the videos to at team
youtube and ask
why is it hate speech to point out hate
speech in someone else's book
why is it hate speech to point out
hypocrisy
why is it hate speech to inform people
about death threats why are muslims
a protected group what are the youtube
privileges of being
in a protected group why is youtube
siding with terrorists why is youtube
protecting and enabling jihadis
ask some questions like that and see if
you get a response
if we can get youtube to explain their
policies it will be much
much easier to expose the bias of the
platform
exciting times ahead